Like all artists, filmmakers have a unique set of tools at their disposal:
cameras, lenses, lights, microphones, music.
And they use these tools to tell their story
or upset a scene.
The director David Lynch has of course
the same tools as everybody else,
but Lynch manipulates more than
just these physical instruments.
More deeply and more strangely,
than any other director I know of
he uses expectation as a tool.
He wields expectation, expectation that comes from what we know about film,
about its history, the history of stories
and from our humanity
with the same nuance and power,
as someone else might use light
to create a variety of moods in a space.
Today I want to look at how Lynch manipulates our expectations in a single scene from his masterpiece "Mulholland Drive".
That guide us towards some
interesting emotional territory.
The scene I'm talking about is one of my favourite ever.
The audition scene, where Betty, played by Naomi Watts, tries out for a part
in a small movie, we later learn is called the
"Sylvia North Story".
The scene occurs about halfway through
the film.
Betty has come to Hollywood, bright eyed and bushy tailed, to be a movie star.
"Of course I'd rather be known as a great actress, than a movie star,
but you know sometimes people end up being both".
She's staying at her aunt's house,
where she discovers Rita
a woman who's been in a car accident
and has lost all her memory.
Our expectations for the audition have
already been set up
by much of what we've witnessed
leading up to the scene.
Betty doesn't seem to be a character
with much internal depth or darkness.
Her flatness of affect is even parodied in
her very first scene at the airport,
where the dialogue is clearly overdubbed
and fake.
"Okay Irene, won't that be the day."
Her blind kindness makes her
vulnerable to exploitation.
She doesn't even really care, that a stranger
is living in her aunt's house.
So coming into the audition we're feeling a couple things
We are somewhat invested in Betty success, a basic expectation for any protagonist,
but more wary of some danger that may be in store because of her innocence
and we have little or no expectation, that she will impress with her acting chops.
"Betty, why don't you join Woody over
there and we'll play the scene."
And of course the last thing to mention is that we've already seen the scene played out once before,
back at the house, practice round to try
out for a trial with Betty and Rita.
"You're still here?"
"I came back. I thought that's what you wanted."
"Nobody wants you here!"
In this first reading the scene is revealed to be trite.
The dialogue clichéd and melodramatic, Betty's character rebukes her father's friend
who is trying to seduce her,
for the second time it seems.
And she moves closer and closer, as her
threats become more stern.
The two women can't even finish without laughing at the soap opera quality of the script.
"Then I cry, cry, cry,"
"and then I say with big emotion: I hate you, I hate us both!"
So a universe of expectation has been
laid out for the viewer.
Will see in a second how those expectations will work as a trap,
but at the start everything in the audition room seems to reinforce what we already think:
the people are about as stiff as the gaudy wood paneling,
Betty's reading partner Woody looks like a star of "All my children", who spent a little too much time in the Sun,
the director is absent minded and
laughable.
So, when the scene begins and Woody crawls Betty
into his slimy grasp,
what triggers first is our awareness
of how vulnerable she is.
And when she pushes him away, we don't know if she's reacting as herself or as the character
"Nobody wants you here!"
Then Woody moves to put his hands below her waist and something incredible happens.
A transformation so sudden, that
the viewer experiences whiplash.
As the critic George Toles notes we allured into engaging emotionally with the scene.
When Lynch triggers our expectation
that Betty might be exploited,
we've dropped our guard a little, but
it's already too much.
We've surrendered enough so that when Lynch switches the bait, we are left in awe at what happens next.
"You know what I want...
it's not that difficult."
"Get out!"
"Get out before I call my dad...
he trusts you...
you're his best friend."
All throughout the film from the overdubbed
dialogue on down
David Lynch has made us privy to the
veneer of things.
It's all curiously two-dimensional
and that puts us on our guard.
Since surfaces are what we get Lynch encourages us to examine those surfaces,
always remaining detached enough for a disinterested critical view of what we're seeing.
But as with everything that Lynch does, this two-dimensionality, this flatness is also a deception.
"...and I know you said you would entertain suggestions
and that's all anybody here is asking you to do."
"What are you talking about?"
While we think we're on our guard, superior to the cloying emotions of Hollywood wish fulfilment,
Lynch relishes dropping the bottom out,
showing us just how unprepared and susceptible we are to emotions that our society treasures or deeply fears.
In a scene that mirrors the audition, Betty and Rita go to a place called club Silencio,
where a special show is underway.
The host repeats again and again:
"No hay banda!"
"There is no band!"
Everything you're hearing he says
is a tape-recording.
Expectations for the scene are made
totally explicit.
Then a woman comes out and sings a truly heartbreaking Spanish version of Roy Orbison's "Crying".
Lynch pushes tight into her face in an extreme close up and the film begins to taunt us.
What's at stake here as in
any movie is belief.
Can the director make you believe the
artifice being presented to you.
That's why directors use expectations we
inculcated from other films.
When two people lock eyes for the first time
and the camera pushes in
that's love at first sight.
This is one way to generate belief.
The definition of expectation is a strong belief that something will happen.
But Lynch goes a step further.
In one way he sets up an expectation, then lures you into believing the opposite.
So when the rug is pulled out, the audience is left suspended, caught out and captured;
engaging fully with the terrifying nothingness that they were warned against.
When the film finally takes its hard right turn revealing Betty's true story of pain and degradation,
we're confronted again with the same feeling, believing we're going to get the key to the mystery,
but instead are only sunk
deeper into the dream.
It's worth noting by the way, that this all comes from an expectation that goes unfulfilled.
But the audition scene plays the reverse
feeling, and I think this is important.
Instead of pulling the rug out to reveal
an abyss
we come in fully prepared and analytical, only to be dropped into a space of raw and honest emotion.
Even though we know it's acted,
even though we know this is a film,
we are entranced, totally believing the moment not because our expectations were fulfilled,
but because they were subverted in a way that we didn't think was possible.
"And then I cry, cry, cry, and then I say with big emotion:
I hate you!"
"I hate us both.."
Not content with the dreams that Hollywood has been feeding us and mass for decades,
David Lynch uses clichéd expectation to move us
into the spaces film has yet to go,
showing us the dangers and
the hopes of believing.
"Oh... I can't believe it"
That's a lot of Lynch in a week period. Anyway
thank you very much for watching, happy Wednesday.
Thank you so much guys for some you know
all the well wishes on my TEDx topic
couple weeks ago to support it just
makes me feel good.
I have to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring this video, they do intuitive
sleek websites where you just you know
go on and start making one
squarespace.com and sign up for a year
you can get a free trial and if you use
offer code nerd writer you can get ten
percent off your first purchase.
Thank you guys, thank you everybody again, I
will see you next Wednesday.